et pour faire le point sur la situation
prend la direction de kiev et notre
correspondant en ukraine bonjour
gulliver craag l'armée ukrainienne
enregistre donc des progrès à kharkiv
oui il semblerait que la
contre-offensive ukrainienne progresse
même si volodymyr zelensky a mis en
garde contre des attentes des victoires
trop rapide mais tous les jours on a des
nouvelles d'une reprise d'un petit bout
de territoire en tout cas au nord et au
nord-est de rare qu'yves le but de cette
opération ce n'est pas uniquement
d'éloigner les forces russes de harkis
vais donc de protéger la deuxième ville
de l'ukraine s'est aussi de couper les
lignes russes qui fournissent les unités
de l'armée russe qui sont plus au sud au
sud de la région dach qu'yves autour de
la ville de is you ce qui est crucial
pour l'offensif russe dans le dos de
basse alors il ya vraiment un aspect
stratégique à ces décisions des
ukrainiens de 2 pouces et de concentrer
leur contre offensive dans cet espace au
nord-est de harkis bonjour d'univers
voilà pour la situation à kharkhiv la
situation n'est pas le même la même dans
le reste du pays les russes poursuivent
leur offensive dans l'est de l'ukraine
oui les russes poursuivent leur
offensive et ils ont des petits gains
des territoires ils sont toujours plus
proches si je comprends bien dedans tour
est du moins la ville de severodonezk
est la plus grande ville sous contre
l'ukrainienne dans la région de lougansk
mais de l'avis des experts américains et
ukrainiens cette offensive progresse
beaucoup beaucoup plus lentement que les
russes ne prévoyait ils rencontrent une
résistance assez forte de la part des
ukrainiens et il est question de combien
de temps les russes peuvent durer avant
que leur mauvais moral et l'épuisement
commence à donner plus de succès aux
ukrainiens qui vont à un moment donné
essayé probablement de lancer des dés
contre offensif mais de toute façon
malgré le progrès très long récemment il
ne faut pas oublier que la russie
contrôlent actuellement une très grande
partie des régions de donetsk et de
louhansk une partie bien sûr elles
contrôlent déjà depuis 2014 y compris
les plus grandes villes donetsk est
lougansk eux mêmes et puis un pont du
sud de l'ukraine aussi hélas les
ukrainiens n'ont pas vraiment de progrès
dans des tentatives de montées des
contre-offensive pour reprendre du
territoire dans le sud